foreign
[Music]
ER time okay right this is a good add a
few extra O's in the goodness
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you might have heard intermittently
every now and then
that Earth's poles will flip have you
ever heard you've heard that right I've
heard people say it say it well thank
you for clarifying that right right and
clarifying that it's not what is true
it's what people say or think is true
these are not always the same thing so
right the it was especially bandied
about when we were approaching not only
the year 2000 but also the year 2012.
about every 10 years people band
together and wanted to clear that the
world is about to end based on some
Cosmetics right I'm intrigued I think
that people need need followers if
you're the one saying the world's going
to end and no one else is people will
think you have special knowledge and
then you become sort of this Guru of
prognostication so let me just make it
clear that Earth's rotation axis with
Santa Claus at the top
is not flipping that is a completely
stable configuration we bob up and down
a little bit okay and so I on our
spinning axis we not only precess which
is a fancy word for wobble
okay we wobble if you have it played
with a top as the top slows down you see
it wobble but also we bob up and down
okay and they all happen on very
different time scales but none of them
involve a flipping of Earth's axis
North and South
however
what does flip are the magnetic poles
the magnetic poles
now let me just nip something in the bud
here okay just so you know uh you're old
enough to have probably used a compass
in your life when you're a kid all right
okay uh which way does the compass
always point
North is what they say okay so that's
that's correct and it points to the
north magnetic pole all right right
which by the way does not exactly align
with Santa Claus
all right okay it's there's by the way
there's things in the universe where
that it's almost at 90 degrees to each
other so there's there's nothing
specially it's it's no Cosmic
pre-requirement that they perfectly
align in the spinning object all right
so in our case they don't align the
North Pole is sitting somewhere in
Northern Canada all right so if you're
trying to find Santa Claus with a
compass and you're in Northern Canada
you're gonna land in the wrong spot
oh wow okay just to be clear about that
I wonder we can't find them
you didn't get your presents you didn't
get your presence this is so good
you didn't get your Pony
exactly I can't find this you're gonna
pay what you owe Santa
[Laughter]
so so it'll find the north magnetic pole
all right so that thing that's pointing
there is the North Pole of the compass
needle
the compass needle is itself a magnet
with a north and a South Pole now here's
here's a little known fact okay
uh what can you tell me about North and
South poles of a magnet
take two magnets together what do they
do well you know they repel each other
if this is the same which repels what
which repels
to North and South to South they each
repel each other right like charges
repel right so wait a minute if the
needle of a compass
that says North on it points to the
North Pole
shouldn't it be
pointing in the opposite direction right
it should be repelled and pointing down
okay except it's not it's attracted
which tells you that Earth's South
magnetic pole is in the North
because the north part of all magnets
point in that direction okay okay
I just I don't know if you knew that no
okay you know like I've here's the thing
you already you what you did was you
took the empirical and put it first yeah
then you said the ridiculous thing
afterwards so now what am I left to do
I'm like well he already proved it so
what am I gonna do like yeah it's pre
it's pre-approved
I can't say like yeah right whatever you
know no no because you already were with
me on it exactly you helped me yes
absolutely right so demonstrate this and
they don't tell you that in the Boy
Scouts no they don't that you're that
the Earth's South magnetic pole is in
the north which is why all North Poles
are magnets point there sorry Little
Tommy but you're screwed uh
this concept of reality is Awesome by
180 degrees all right so here's what
happens uh we have a magnetic field
because our core
is fluid all right all the heavy stuff
when Earth was molten uh heavy stuff
fell to the middle and the heavy stuff
is the iron and the light stuff which is
the Rocks floated to the top okay and we
don't think of rocks as light but it's
much lighter than metal all right and so
all the metals nearly all the metals
went to the core some got frozen in
place as we have these oars these veins
of ores as Earth is solidifying it
didn't fall down fast enough and it got
frozen in place there are other
occasions where volcanoes can
redistribute material from below and put
it up in the crust but basically most of
Earth's iron is in our core and it's hot
and so the iron is molten and we have
molten and you're spinning you have
moving
magnetically uh chargeable Metals okay
iron is is magnetizable when you have
moving metal you create what's called a
Dynamo
and in a Dynamo you basically create a
magnetic field from scratch
wow that's why old dead planets that
have cooled do not have magnetic fields
right
okay they don't they don't have many
fields like Mars no magnetic field to
speak of okay because it's it's cooled
faster than Earth did it's smaller so
cool if you're smaller you will cool
faster and so no there's no you don't
have these this churning uh by the way
Mars once did for sure Mars has the
largest known volcano in the solar
system okay so Mars used to be hot on
the inside but that's called Olympus
Mons all right makes our volcanoes look
like mole Hills by the way it's huge
it's huge so anyhow the point I'm
getting at here is the Dynamo goes
through Cycles
okay and it goes It goes It goes
stronger then it goes weaker and it
flips
and so every half million years or so
the magnetic field of Earth has flipped
period okay that's pretty wild okay yeah
it's it's it's fascinating and while
it's flipping it actually goes to zero
and then recover is coming out the other
side
makes me ask what does the magnetic
field of Earth do for Earth and do for
us other than give compasses a meaning
in life other than confused
um Boy Scouts who don't understand that
that the company should be pointing in
the opposite direction well Einstein was
quite intrigued by a compass that some
mysterious force that you can't see
touch smell or taste is forcing the
needle to move he was very intrigued by
that as a child
so I think we'll be thankful that we had
compasses back if it was just GPS with a
handheld device finding North I think
maybe Einstein would not you know he
might have gone on to play basketball or
something who knows who knows what
career he might have had
so actually that's the opposite of a
Gary Larson comic that's where I got
that idea from there's a picture of
Einstein on a basketball court and he's
like dribbling right and it said uh
Albert Einstein in school was destined
to be to be uh you know All-Star
basketball player until an ankle injury
physics books
so so the point is that so the median
field has flipped and what the magnetic
field does when it's operating is it
creates a magnetic shield around Earth
if you will and when charged particles
come from the Sun the solar wind we call
it they see this magnetic field and they
spiral down towards the poles
aha or towards the magnetic poles and as
they spiral down they careen into air
molecules and we have two molecules that
collide with each other energy gets
exchanged okay so your your energy of
motion gets boosted into the energy
inside the molecule itself so you've
excited the molecule then on its own
timetable like fractions of a second it
de-excites and then radiates visible
light
so wait a minute what is that oh I know
what that is that's the Aurora that's
pretty wild the Aurora Borealis that's
in the north and take it take a gander
what it's called in the south
um the uh
let me see
um
the Southern Aurora Borealis okay thank
you
uh you know I'm okay with that notice
the Aurora Australis
right okay because it's symmetric right
we have a North Pole and a South Pole so
we make a big deal of our own Aurora
because 90 of the human population of
the world lives north of the equator
right so we get Aurora so there it is
and and we know the field is flipped you
know why because you can see volcanic
planes where iron came out and the iron
aligned with the magnetic field when it
froze in place
and you compare this from different
generations of volcanic eruptions and
you can see the flipping of the
orientation of the of the iron particles
that is it's it's remarkable that is
really outstanding that's pretty wild
because yeah the the the the the mag
it's a magnet so it's metal in a magnet
and it's actually
um um uh it's doing its thing so coming
to the properties of Mac of magnetism
correct correct and if Earth is helping
that out it's going to align them when
it freezes out of the volcanic uh flow
so yeah no it's pretty cool stuff and it
all comes together and by the way this
involved like astrophysicists and
geologists and there's a plus there was
a worry if we don't have a magnetic
field
that means the charged particles sum
straight into us and don't get directed
to the poles would that be bad for life
on Earth so it might be you might think
it would be
but they're no particularly striking
Extinction episodes right at the times
when the magnetic fields of the zero
yeah there's no there's no we've by the
way animals are going extinct all the
time especially now because humans have
have their hands in this process
we're told is the sixth Extinction
really wow all right uh so
um so yeah that's in case you didn't
know that your compass points South
that's great
all right that's all we got time for it
Chuck always good to have you there
always a pleasure all right this has
been a Star Talk explainer Neil deGrasse
Tyson keep looking up
[Music]